the Harvard happiness study this study
over a hundred years two cohorts of men
removing economic differences and
educational opportunities removing those
to look at them as a same meaning you
have your less wealthy cohort your more
wealthy and educated cohort and they
discovered at the end of the day for
both groups the happiest healthiest men
were the ones that ended up choosing
long-term marriages and staying married
you found misery bankruptcy lack of
Health in both groups of men even the
ones that were wealthy and from good
educational backgrounds versus not and
you found better outcomes for both
groups of men including the poorer group
the less educated group when they
married and when they stayed married and
built families were made for connection
we made for long-term committed
relationship